[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous si vous
regardez l'échiquier mondial duels
au sommaire aujourd'hui le qatar et les
émirats arabes unis une relation
historiquement complexe marquée par une
antipathie personnelle des familles
dirigeantes
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici une brève
présentation des dirigeants de ces deux
monarchies rival du golfe c'est le blitz
âgé de 60 ans mohammed ben zayed et le
fils de zayed ben sultan al nahyan le
fondateur des émirats arabes unis et son
premier président il fait ses études à
abou dhabi jusqu'à l'âge de 18 ans avant
d'être envoyé à l'académie militaire
royale de sandhurst en angleterre lieu
de passage pour de nombreux membres des
familles dirigeantes du golfe c'est
aussi à sanders que le futur adversaire
de mbz tamim ben hamad al thani de 19
ans son cadet poursuit une formation en
1998 tamim est le fils de ahmad ben
khalifa le précédent émirs et membres de
la famille al thani au pouvoir au qatar
depuis la fin du 19e siècle alors que
tamim al-thani va encore à l'école mbz
grimpe déjà les échelons politiques du
pays en 1986 il est nommé commandant de
l'armée de l'air et six ans plus tard il
est promu au poste de chef d'état-major
des armées qu'il occupera jusqu'en 2015
à cette fonction il entreprend de
réformer les forces armées en les
professionnalisantes en modernisant
leurs équipements et surtout en
centralisant le commandement pour tamim
al-thani l'ascension politique commence
à la suite de sa désignation comme
prince héritier en 2003 dans les années
qui suivent il prend en charge de
nombreux dossiers notamment dans les
domaines de l'enseignement du sport ou
de la communication il est en outre le
commandant en chef adjoint des forces
armées du qatar tamim est perçu par ses
interlocuteurs comme un homme ouvert et
affable mais dans le même temps
conservateurs et prudents
mohamed zayed nommé prince héritier en
2004 prend une part de plus en plus
grande dans le gouvernement civil en
devenant notamment président du conseil
exécutif de l'émirat d'abou dhabi
il voit son rôle renforcé à partir de
2014 lorsque son frère le président de
la fédération des émirats est victime
d'un accident vasculaire
cérébrale sur le plan international
outre le renforcement des alliances déjà
établies notamment avec les états unis
il poursuit la politique d'opposition
aux frères musulmans et à l'iran d'amis
mme ben hamad al thani quant à lui est
nommé émirats 33 ans par son père qui a
dit qu en sa faveur en 2013
une première au qatar tout en continuant
la politique de son père y multiplient
les contacts diplomatiques
principalement à partir de 2017 afin de
rompre l'isolément auquel le condamne
ses partenaires arabes
le relatif échec du blocus économique
auquel le petit émirat est soumis à
renforcer la popularité du jeune et
mirent au sein de son pays il aurait pu
être compatriotes mais tout a changé au
dernier moment en désaccord avec les
principes de la toute nouvelle
fédération des émirats arabes unis le
qatar choisi en 1971 de faire cavalier
seul
c'est le point de départ des rivalités
économie défense haute technologie
influence médiatique et surtout
diplomatie car les deux états ont une
vision géopolitique totalement
différente de la région leur intérêt se
heurte en libye en somalie au liban où
ils soutiennent des camps opposés
or ce qui fâche le plus les émirats
c'est l'amitié et du qatar avec l'iran
et la turquie les deux étant vu par abou
dhabi comme une menace directe pour
leurs intérêts dans la région
l'antipathie entre les deux familles
dirigeantes ne fait qu'aggraver la
situation
le rétablissement rapide des relations
diplomatiques rompues après la crise
diplomatique survenu il ya quatre ans
semble compromis quelles sont les
principales pierres d'achoppement dans
les relations qatar aux émirats qui
commet l'antipathie personnel des deux
dirigeants affecte tels les relations
bilatérales qui a le plus de chances de
remporter ce duel pour répondre à ces
questions nous rejoignons tout de suite
sébastien boussois chercheur en sciences
politiques est associé à l'université
libre de bruxelles
spécialiste du moyen-orient monsieur
vous soit bonjour je voudrais vous tout
d'abord parlons de mohammed ben zayed
depuis qu'il a vraiment pris les rênes
du pouvoir il semble avoir de grandes
ambitions pour le rôle de son pays au
moins dans la région qu'en est il
vous ce n'est rien de le dire c'est vrai
que ce micro confettis géopolitique est
arrivé en quelques années depuis
notamment les printemps arabes à une
situation stratégique extrêmement
importante et des relations de plus en
plus développées avec les grandes
puissances régionales et avec le monde
en termes d'intégration on peut dire que
mohamed ben zayed a réussi son coup mais
il veut aller plus loin en réalité c'est
un militaire c'est un stratège et son
objectif est de transformer les émirats
arabes unis auparavant forme d'îlots
libéral dans la région en une nouvelle
start ce que certains considèrent comme
une nouvelle spark moi je dirais une
nouvelle venise c'est à dire une
puissance complète maritime économique
stratégique culturel financière et pour
ça il l'a mis en place une stratégie
très propre aux émirats comme l'on
retrouve d'ailleurs du côté de son rival
le qatari c'est à dire une stratégie de
soft power et de hard power à tout prix
maintenant tamim al-thani comment
voit-il lui le rôle du qatar dans le
monde arabe et surtout at-il lui les
moyens de ses ambitions
je dirais que dans la région le qatar et
les émirats ont toujours une grande
partie des moyens de leurs ambitions et
en tout cas il les trouve d'un côté vous
avez moins men ben zayed comme je vous
le disais qu'ils étaient plutôt un
militaire et qui était dans une
stratégie sur la région d'empêcher les
révolutions des printemps arabes
d'empêcher l'émergence de mouvements
alternatifs aux autocraties est donc un
moyen pour lui de cadenasser la voix
arabes comme on l'appelle est souvent
malheureusement qui était incarnée par
les frères musulmans qui sont son ennemi
numéro un qui vous avez dans le côté le
qatar et les minimales al thani qui
était en dans cette stratégie depuis
2010 2011 de soutenir les mouvements
alternatifs et donc les mouvements
révolutionnaires qui était contraire aux
dictatures qui était en place depuis des
années et donc il ya eu un moment un
soutien au mouvement alternatif dans une
logique de démocratie les frères
musulmans dont le qatar a pris une
grande distance depuis mais là toute la
difficulté que l'un et l'autre ont une
vision complètement différent du
moyen-orient le qatar vise à une
alternance démocratique qui passerait
par la société civile
et des partis politiques déjà constitués
et de l'autre côté le mohamed zayed qui
est plutôt dans la logique de remettre
en place pions des régimes autoritaires
comme il l'a fait en l'egypte comme il a
essayé de le faire en libye
et comme il le prouve avec son son
soutien à gauche à droite plus récemment
à des régimes forts merci beaucoup
monsieur boussois nous allons poursuivre
notre analyse tout de suite mais nous
vous retrouverons à la fin de cette
émission pour plus de détails sur ce
duel
merci encore entre le qatar et les
émirats arabes unis la rivalité va
crescendo depuis les années 90
antipathie entre les familles
dirigeantes vision différente des
alliances régionales tout cela affecte
fortement le rapport de forces au
moyen-orient et bascule en crise
diplomatique dans la plus grave éclate
en 2017
le 5 juin 2010 est l'arabie saoudite les
émirats arabes unis le bahreïn et
l'egypte organise un blocus économique
et diplomatique du qatar avec la
fermeture des frontières terrestres
aériennes et maritimes
la cause en est la diffusion par l'
agence de presse qatar news agency
en mai 2010 est d'une déclaration
attribuée à l'émir du qatar favorable à
l'iran au hamas et au hezbollah
le qatar dément ces informations qui
résulte selon lui d'un piratage de qatar
news agency
mais le coup est déjà porté le quatuor
arabe avance un ultimatum de 13 points à
doha à qui il est notamment demandé de
réduire ses liens avec l'iran de cesser
son appui à des groupes désignés comme
terroristes notamment les frères
musulmans et de fermer la base militaire
turc de son territoire
en outre la chaîne al jazira doit cesser
ses activités
cependant le qatar ne cède pas à la
pression d'autant qu'il bénéficie de
l'aide de l'iran et de la turquie
plusieurs tentatives de réconciliation
sont entreprises dans les années qui
suivent
mais elle échoue tout ce n'est qu'à la
fin de l'année 2020 que les choses
commencent à bouger la médiation
américaine est qu etienne abouti à la
conclusion de l'accord d'al oula en
janvier 2021 mettant fin au blocus du
qatar
la frontière terrestre avec l'arabie
saoudite est rouverte ainsi que les
voies aériennes et maritimes avec les
autres états du golfe
cependant les tensions persistent entre
le qatar et les émirats arabes unis dont
le dirigeant le prince mohammed bin
zayed reste partisan d'une ligne dure
face à dos à la crise diplomatique est
officiellement terminée et le blocus
imposé au qatar levée pourtant les
relations diplomatiques entre doha et
abu dhabi ne sont toujours pas rétablis
pourquoi la réponse est en partie donné
par la diplomatie émirati certains
problèmes sont plus faciles à résoudre
et d'autres prendront plus de temps nous
avons un très bon départ mais nous avons
des problèmes au niveau du
rétablissement de la confiance
cependant est il possible de rétablir la
confiance sachant que le qatar refuse de
modifier sa ligne politique
à l'international il n'y a eu aucune
concession d'aucun côté la crise du ccg
étaient une situation perdante pour tout
le monde donc mettre fin à cette crise
je pense sera un gain pour tout le monde
parmi les sujets de discorde qui
empoisonne le plus les relations
bilatérales figure la coopération du
qatar avec l'iran et la turquie
elle prend un nouveau souffle suite à
l'imposition du blocus à doha par le
quatuor arabe téhéran et ankara tendent
alors la main au qatar en
l'approvisionnement en nourriture eau et
médicaments
les relations irano qatari se développe
ainsi dans plusieurs domaines commerce
énergie technologie la coopération turco
qatarie elle se renforce également dans
le domaine de la défense les livraisons
d'armes exercices conjoints et une
présence militaire turque au qatar ce
n'est donc pas par hasard si la rupture
avec la turquie et l'iran figurait parmi
les premières conditions de la levée du
blocus posées par le quatuor arabe en
tout comme ses alliés du golfe abu dhabi
considère ankara et téhéran comme une
menace directe à ses intérêts dans la
région l'iran et la turquie sont de plus
en plus présents dans la région en
utilisant l'ingérence étrangère comme un
outil pour faire avancer leurs
programmes expansionniste
plus précisément abou dhabi accuse
téhéran et ankara dessous
pire les groupes islamistes radicaux
dans le cas de la turquie
il s'agit principalement des frères
musulmans qui sont montés en puissance à
la suite des bouleversements dans le
monde arabe au début des années 2010 abu
dhabi considère cette organisation comme
une menace potentielle pour la pérennité
de son pouvoir héréditaire monarchique
et la qualifie de terroristes les rangs
lui coopérerait avec le hezbollah le
hamas et d'autres
or ce qui inquiète surtout abou dhabi
c'est l' influence croissante de téhéran
dans la région son désengagement de
l'accord nucléaire et le développement
des missiles balistiques
en plus d'une vision totalement
différent de l'échiquier régional et
l'existant un autre facteur qui
complexifie davantage le rapprochement
aimé râteau qatari des relations
complexes entre les familles dirigeants
du qatar et des émirats
l'antipathie mutuelle prend ses racines
dans le coup d'état au qatar de 1995
celui ci est le fruit de désaccord entre
l'émir khalifa ben hamad al thani au
pouvoir depuis 1972 et son fils ahmad
ben khalifa al thani
ce dernier renverse son père alors qu'il
était en visite à genève
à ce moment là les émirats arabes unis
allié fiable du qatar à l'époque offre
refuge à l'émir déchu et soutiennent la
ligne parallèle d' al thani père dans
l'organisation d'un contrecoup en 1996
une tentative est déjouée par le nouvel
émir son cousin organisateur principal
du conte recours ainsi que 32 autres
comploteurs sont condamnés à la prison à
perpétuité
comment les deux états se livre-t-il
cette lutte d'influencé dans la région
dans quels domaines la rivalité imera
tôt qatari était la plus prononcée
quel est le rapport de force dans ce
duel la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
la diplomatie offensive du nouvel émir
qatari n'a fait que creuser le fossé
entre les deux et à la coopération avec
l'iran et la turquie
le soutien des mouvements rebelles dans
le monde arabe au début des années 2010
enfin la création d'al jazeera qui
promeut la vision qatari de la région
l'arrivée au pouvoir de tamim ben hamad
al thani en 2013 ne change pas grand
chose
il continue la ligne de son père qui
hérite de plus en plus les émirats
arabes unis ces derniers temps le qatar
se voit coincé entre les deux poids
lourds régionaux
l'arabie saoudite du côté terrestre et
l'iran de l'autre côté du golfe persique
dans ces conditions doha cherche un
équilibre entre l'amitié de ryad et la
coopération avec téhéran
abou dhabi se rangent principalement du
côté de ryad et considère téhéran comme
une menace à ses intérêts dans la région
à part l'arabie saoudite les émirats
maintiennent des liens étroits avec le
bahreïn l'egypte et depuis peu rétabli
ses relations avec israël la presse
israélienne dévoile même les projets de
création d'une alliance de défense
régionale de son côté doha renforce de
plus en plus sa coopération avec la
turquie dans les domaines du commerce de
l'enseignement et de la défense
la turquie a une présence militaire au
qatar depuis 2016 la rivalité
géopolitiques entre les monarchies du
golfe se voit aussi sur le continent
africain en libye par exemple le qatar
soutient et compris militairement le
gouvernement d'union nationale de fayez
al sa rage alors que les émirats puis
l'armée nationale libyenne du maréchal
haftar la corne de l'afrique fait elle
aussi l'objet de convoitises
le qatar coopère étroitement avec la
somalie les émirats se renforce de plus
en plus leur présence au somaliland
le récent conflit entre israël et la
palestine a été un vrai test d'
influence pour les deux duellistes pour
le qatar l'enjeu est de soutenir ses
alliés de longue date les militants
palestiniens dès le début de l' escalade
en mai doit prend résolument le côté du
hamas le ministre qatari des affaires
étrangères multiplient aussi des
rencontres
avec les chefs de l'organisation le
qatar propose même sa médiation pour le
cessez le feu
au final ce sont les efforts de l'egypte
qui met fin aux hostilités mais doit
aurait aussi joué son rôle selon la bbc
face à l'implication active qatar et les
émirats arabes unis se retrouvent en
position délicate car en 2020 ils ont
normalisé leurs relations avec israël et
les liens entre deux états ne cesse de
s'intensifier
du coup dans la crise israélo
palestinienne abou dhabi préfère ne pas
risquer ses perspectives avec tel-aviv
et tempère le discours les émirats
arabes unis appelle les deux parties à
entreprendre des mesures urgentes pour
un cessez le feu ainsi qu'à entamer le
dialogue politique et faire preuve d'un
maximum de retenue dans leurs actions
pourtant les émirats cherche malgré tout
des moyens pour peser dans la résolution
de cette crise il se propose par exemple
en médiateur pour consolider le cessez
le feu
pourtant cette proposition reste pour
l'instant sans suite
le qatar lui poursuit sur sa lancée
diplomatique qui organise une campagne
de dons pour reconstruire gaza et ce
n'est pas le seul front régional ou doha
consolide son influence
le qatar revient aussi sur celle dans le
règlement du conflit en syrie en février
doit reçoit le chef de la coalition
nationale syrienne de l'opposition
nasser al hariri pendant la visite le
qatar organise aussi une rencontre avec
l'ambassadeur de turquie ce qui donne à
doha un prétexte pour prétendre au rôle
de médiateur en syrie début mars le
qatar annonce le lancement d'un nouveau
processus trilatérale de consultation
sur le règlement syrien avec la turquie
et la russie en syrie doit utilise ses
liens avec l'opposition pour étendre son
influence
abu dhabi lui préfère miser sur le
président bachar el-assad depuis trois
ans déjà les relations entre les émirats
et damas connaissent un réchauffement
une position hors du commun pour le
monde arabe mais qui plaît à la russie
ainsi en mars abou dhabi reçoit le chef
de la diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov
pendant la visite son homologue émirati
fait un geste pour montrer la solidarité
avec moscou sur la question syrienne
il se prononce pour le retour de la
série dans la ligue arabe et critique
les sanctions américaines contre damas
qu'il considère contre-productive quant
au liban voisin là les émirats ne se
contente pas du rôle d'observateurs
extérieurs
abu dhabi participe au règlement de la
crise dans ce pays sans gouvernement
depuis dix mois
le royaume parrainent le processus de
formation du cabinet entamée par la
france en septembre 2020 ainsi le
premier ministre libanais désigné saad
hariri mènent des consultations
régulières avec les pouvoirs émirati
sauf que le qatar cherche aussi à jouer
un rôle plus actif au liban et pour ce
faire il mise sur sa puissance
financière en février doit à offre au
liban un vaste programme
d'investissements pour soulager la crise
économique
à une condition pourtant le liban doit
d'abord se doter d'un gouvernement et le
qatar souhaite participer à sa formation
nous travaillons à compléter les efforts
internationaux pour former le
gouvernement libanais sortie de l'
isolement doha s'affirme de plus en plus
sur la scène diplomatique
les émirats s'adapte en choisissant une
approche plus pragmatique aux affaires
régionales comment leur confrontation se
joue-t-elle sur d'autres fronts avant
d'aller plus loin
faisons le récap deuxième puissance
économique au sein du conseil de
coopération des états du golfe derrière
l'arabie saoudite les émirats arabes
unis disposent de près de 6 % des
réserves mondiales de pétrole là
production d'hydrocarbures leur assure
près de 30% du budget pourtant
aujourd'hui abou dhabi misé gros sur la
diversification de l'économie et
développe activement le secteur des
services notamment le tourisme et les
activités portuaires et aéroportuaires
le qatar lui est le cinquième producteur
mondial de gaz deuxième exportateur de
gaz est plus grand exportateur de gnl
tout comme abou dhabi doha diversifie
son économie en investissant dans la
santé l'éducation la recherche le sport
et le tourisme
sur le plan de la communication doit
possède un outil médiatique puissant el
jazeera première chaîne d'information en
arabe en continu qui a bouleversé à
l'époque le paysage médiatique de la
région ce média qatari qui donne la
parole à des opposants politiques au
régime fort du monde arabe déplaît
fortement notamment à ses voisins du
golfe
or ces derniers temps son influence est
remise en cause par son concurrent
saoudiens al-arabiya paru en 2003
l'autre domaine de rivalité entre les
émirats et le qatar et la défense
à partir des années 90 abu dhabi
augmente progressivement ses dépenses
militaires
aujourd'hui son armée fait partie du top
5 des armées les plus puissantes du
moyen-orient selon le classement annuel
de global firepower le qatar quant à lui
bien l'année dernière d'entrer dans le
top 10 des plus grands importateurs
mondiaux d'armement selon l'institut
international de recherche sur la paix
basé à stockholm
cependant les deux pays du fait de leur
faible population ont désarmé limitée en
effectif pendant le blocus la
confrontation entre le qatar et les
émirats arabes unis atteint son pic
abu dhabi mais la pression maximale sur
doha et sa campagne ne se limite pas aux
mesures officielles ainsi sur le plan
économique les émirats et leurs alliés
impose un strict blocus au qatar mais
parallèlement il déploie toute une
stratégie secrète
en 2010 est une alliance de trois
banques auraient manipulé les marchés
pour faire chuter le cours du rial
qatariens et asphyxié son système
financier
c'est ce qu'affirme le qatar dans sa
plainte déposée en justice en 2019 une
thèse confirmée en partie en décembre
dernier par bloomberg
selon lagence en 2017 la banque
havilland a bien préparé un plan concret
pour attaquer les marchés financiers du
qatar et ce à la demande du prince
héritier émirati une attaque à laquelle
doit réussi à résister même si cela lui
coûte 40 milliards de dollars pour
soutenir le cours de sa monnaie le qatar
s'adapte rapidement au blocus et son
économie ne cesse de croître
or il doit aussi faire face à une
campagne d' attaques informatiques
le 24 mai 2010 est l' agence officielle
d'information qatarie q ena publie un
discours de l'émir al thani des propos
très controversés ou le chef d'état en
ce sens les mouvements islamistes tels
que le hamas le hezbollah les frères
musulmans puis glorifie l'iran par ya
des monarchies sunnites
la publication est vite retirée mais les
citations ont le temps d'embraser les
médias saoudiens et émiratis
le mal est fait dix jours après lé
royaume du golfe lance le boycott contre
doha le qatar accuse les émirats d'avoir
piraté le site de l'agencé
coïncidence ou pas une semaine après
c'est abou dhabi qui subit une attaque
informatique
le 4 juin 2010 est des acteurs inconnus
public des emails de l'ambassadeur des
émirats à washington
s'ensuit multitude de révélations
embarrassantes plus particulièrement
abou dhabi semble avoir mené une large
campagne médiatique pour dénigrer
l'image du qatar
à l'international le domaine
cybernétique devient un vrai champ de
bataille pendant toute la période du
blocus arabe de doha abu dhabi aurait
utilisé les hautes technologies pour
espionner son adversaire selon les
chercheurs canadiens elle était 2020 les
émirats en pirate
les portables de dizaines de
journalistes d'al jazeera
et d'après le new york times en 2014
le royaume établi même tout un réseau
électronique d'espionnage au qatar en
même temps sur les réseaux sociaux
des centaines de milliers de bottes
s'affrontent sur twitter pour promouvoir
la vision d'une des deux parties dans
cette campagne le qatar n'hésite pas à
utiliser à plein régime son puissant
outil médiatique al jazeera par exemple
pour faire dérailler l'accord de
normalisation entre les émirats et
israël avant sa signature en septembre
dernier
al jazeera organise une large campagne
anti-israélienne à l'image violence
contre les palestiniens
maisons détruites à gaza des titres
terrifiant euro pris dans les journaux
un contraste vif avec les médias du
quatuor arabe qui tente au contraire
d'adoucir l'image de tel-aviv et de
préparer l'opinion arabe à la
normalisation des relations
pour y voir plus clair nous rejoignons
deux nouveaux sébastien boussois
chercheur en sciences politiques associé
à l'université libre de bruxelles
spécialiste du moyen orient monsieur
boussois le blocus arabe imposé sur le
qatar s'est achevée sans grand résultat
quelle est la stratégie après blocus des
émirats pour contrer dois je crois que
là le rapprochement n'est que de façade
le qatar s'est rapproché de nouveau de
l'arabie saoudite ce qui a permis en
2021 de mettre fin à ce fameux 2020-2021
mettre fin à ce fameux blocus mais les
émirats continuent à en découdre parce
que leur objectif est notable leader
dans la région au moment où l'arabie
saoudite est plutôt dans une forme de
ralentissement un mohammed salman qui a
une image détestable des stratégies
économiques qui n'avance pas un problème
de diversification de l'économie la
sphère fashion j vous avez mohammed ben
zayed en sous main qui depuis des années
installe ses alliés et développe une
économie extrêmement extrêmement
dynamique donc l'objectif est de
continuer au delà de la bataille
économique dans une bataille politique
contre le qatar dans une bataille
médiatique et les fakes news continue à
aarau
le qatar et on sait très bien que ça
vient en grande partie d'une cyber
organisation et d'une finalement de d'un
cybers hacking dont les émirats arabes
unis se sont fait la spécialité avec
leur soutien israélien depuis un certain
nombre d'années
je crois que ça ne s'arrêtera pas là et
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
les choses vont monter en puissance avec
d'un côté l'exposition universelle vers
lequel tous les regards seront portés de
l'autre côté la coupe du monde de
football où comme par hasard vous avez
tout un tas d'affaires qui sortent et
qui ressortent et dont on sait
clairement qu'elles sont dictées par
l'agenda politique d'aidé émirati
soutenu par les saoudiens qui aimeraient
en finir définitivement de leur rival
principal qu'est le qatar dans la région
qui sortira gagnant du coup de tous ces
événements de cette guerre énergétique
informationnelle et politique la voix de
la raison je ne peux pas parler d'un
acteur en particulier on voit bien qu'il
ya un axe qui s'est défini un axe israël
aux sunnites depuis quelques années
contre un axe qui serait qui serait chic
le tout est d'éviter que le monde arabe
et le monde arabo musulman se divise
davantage je crois qu'à travers des
événements à travers des négociations il
faut revenir au multilatéralisme qui
avait abandonné
donald trump je dirais que mohammed ben
zayed a perdu comme rahman bin salman un
allié de poids dans tous les sens du
terme avec donald trump et on est
aujourd'hui du coup dans peut-être la
possibilité si joe biden décide un peu
de se réinvestir dans la région de faire
revenir le multilatéralisme et d'éviter
à un accord de nouveau avec l'iran de se
retrouver dans une situation de tension
qui pourrait rapidement glissé vers une
guerre personne n'en a aucun intérêt je
crois qu'il est temps que joe biden se
réveille sur ce dossier là certes la
chine et la mer jaune sont une priorité
on l'a bien compris pour les etats-unis
mais sans paix au moyen-orient ou en
tout cas sans réduction des crises
telles qu'elles sont c'est très bien que
le monde restera en danger merci
beaucoup monsieur boussois je rappelle
sébastien boussois chercheur en sciences
politiques associé à l'université libre
de bruxelles spécialiste du moyen orient
et est aujourd'hui avec nous pour
apporter son éclairage merci beaucoup
encore cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]